in the beginning of your writing career
how are you green on the business side
of being a TV writer
oh my God I was so green about the whole
thing it's you know when your first
break in right the writer's Guild one of
the main things that they do for us is
the negotiate the
um MBA which is our minimum basic
agreement with the studios so there's
set amounts that studio that staff
writers will make so it's written down
it's like they're in a piece of paper so
you don't have to there's not a ton of
negotiation when you're a staff writer
but as you go on like all of this stuff
gets very complicated and there's you
know issues of um how long a studio can
hold you and how much more they have to
pay you to hold you and it gets very
complicated which is why having a rep
that you can communicate with is so
important because I have literally just
had to say to my agent my manager
sometimes like what does this mean I
don't understand this what does this
mean
and you know just in terms of
how
how your career is going to build it's
sort of like an idea in the beginning
but it really is sort of
one job at a time one project at a time
because I very much my reps would tell
you every time a project ends I'm like
you're gonna be able to find me another
job right and they're like girl of
course you're gonna find another job but
I can't believe my own press so I'm
always like am I gonna want another job
though
um but it's you know paying attention to
the business paying attention to all
this consolidation that's going on
um you know are the people that you knew
who worked at Netflix getting laid off
or did they survive the layoffs because
sometimes you're reaching out to the
people you know to say like hey I have
this project and I'm looking for someone
who might be interested in it does it
seem to you like one of your overall
people might be interested in this or
something you know to your friends and
if your friends are in these Mass
layoffs now they're off looking for
different work
um
how systems change you know having
worked at marble TV in its old
Incarnation and then that whole thing
going away so everybody I knew who
worked for Marvel didn't work for Marvel
anymore you know in a matter of a year
so the whole marble TV landscape has
changed and so it's like okay who who
does work over there do I know anyone
there so you're you're constantly having
to pay attention to the evolution of
this business there are people who
choose not to there are people who are
like that's just too much for me I don't
want to deal with it I like to be
informed about all those things I think
it's really important to me so that when
my agent sends me something from a
particular Studio or a producing pod
that I am like oh they're connected to
this place I don't really love maybe I
don't want to look at this or oh I love
that place so yes let's definitely work
there
um so it I just think that edge you're
always educating yourself not just about
your skill set that you need as a writer
but about
how to be you know how to be a share
runner in the future about how this
business works
about what good representation looks
like you know I constantly have younger
writers saying to me you know like
um having this problem with my agent but
I don't want to say anything and I'm
like no no your agent works for you
they work for you you want to have a
good partnership with them but they get
paid because you get paid so it's fine
to go to them and say hey I'm a little
concerned about X can we talk about it
and it's it's fascinating how many
younger writers are scared to have those
conversations so you know we're we're
all encouraging them to go do that
you know there's a
there's a lot about it I still don't
know you know if you ask me to explain
to you half the stuff in my feature
contract I would tell you I would need
to talk to my future agent again because
she explained it all to me and I
remember half of it but a whole bunch of
it I'm like oh I don't actually remember
how that bonus gets triggered I would
have to ask my feature agent so it's a
lot and it's really important to work
with people that you feel like you can
trust who are giving you the best advice
and a younger writer would be scared to
ask or push the envelope because they
feel like I'm finally in the door I
don't want to jeopardize it that's it
absolutely like sometimes it takes so
long to get wrapped it's so hard to get
representation and they get scared of
rocking the boat because they don't want
to be without a rep
um I had a conversation with a writer
who gave me really wonderful advice and
it was that it is honestly better to be
unrepresented than to have the wrong rep
because the wrong rep is holding you
back like it sucks to not be represented
because there's stuff it's harder to
submit for you have to try to like can
your lawyer submit you if you have a
lawyer it all gets very tricky but if
you have a rep who isn't doing the work
isn't sending you out on General
meetings so that you can build a
reputation amongst Executives and
amongst producers of someone they want
to work with
they're not helping you build your
career and so it's fine to say look I
totally get that you're super busy could
you maybe put someone more Junior on my
team who can help me set up more General
meetings because I really want to
you know get to coep in the next five
years and so I need to get out there and
meet these people and be on that path
it's perfectly fine to say that because
you can frame it in a way that's not
you're not doing your job it's I totally
get that you have bigger clients than me
so would it be okay if we tried this
and if they say no they're not the right
rep for you they're just not
tips for the TV writer's room like
things that a new writer might not think
of in terms of maybe where to sit
um what if they're fidgety yes yes there
there are so many things that I feel
like I talk about in the register and
survival guide that will seem silly to
people who have never worked in a
writer's room but they're so important
and so for instance
um the you know the first day you get
there and it's sort of like where does
everybody sit if it's a returning show
there are probably people who already
have seats that they like so kind of
like hang back and see what's going on
or you can say does anybody sit here
and they'll tell you if someone does or
not right
um if it's if you're the kind of writer
who is very fidgety and like you like to
draw constantly or you're like a leg
Bouncer and you need to be bouncing your
leg or you know you're you take pens
apart I've worked with writers who do
that
don't sit by your show runner because
your showrunner's attention is going to
constantly be pulled to you and that
might be a problem for you so sit across
the room just sit across the room and do
your thing you got to do to feel
comfortable but it won't be right in
your showrunner's face if you are the
kind of writer who
has to go to the bathroom every hour sit
closer to the door so you can just get
up and slip out and come back in and it
won't be any big drama because no one
wants to be the person who has to walk
across the entire writer's room every
hour it's like it's you don't nobody
wants to do it so just save yourself the
problem
um you know when it comes to lunch
orders this is a big one so in a lot of
rooms the studio will provide lunch for
the writers when you're meeting in
person
and there's limits to how much you can
spend and so there's usually like a an
assembly of menus of places that you can
go to right
if it's your day to pick and you don't
want to pick just pass it on just be
like I don't want to pick today someone
else pick
if it's your day to pick and you know
that the place you want to go is a place
that everybody hates please do not pick
that place
because they're all gonna be mad at you
um if you know if you notice that your
share runner's a little grumpy today and
you know what his favorite place is pick
his favorite place
because it's like he's going to be real
happy when he's like oh we're going
there today great and suddenly his mood
gets better
um
so it's just it's a lot of silly kind of
little things but because it's a room
full of personalities that have to find
a way to coexist together those things
can be really important so I I you know
hopefully people will think about those
things when they walk in there for the
first time
are writing credits your ticket to
getting better and better work
they can be for sure
um there there are people in this
business and I will just say that who
are what we refer to as credit snobs
right so for example when I was coming
up and I had done four broadcast shows
in a row there were people at some of
the streamers and stuff who were like
well but she's only done broadcast
well then I went and did Cloak and
Dagger and I wrote a movie and suddenly
I was really cool right because I had a
cool credit and I had written a movie
and I'm like
what I did in those procedural rooms is
harder than any of the stuff that you're
like oh she's so cool for because when
you have to break a crime
16 18 22 times
with the same character solving it but
you have to find a way to make it cool
and different every week trust me that's
harder than anything you're going to ask
me to write in any of your snobby rooms
certainly say that you know once I
transition to more streaming content and
that kind of stuff
the stuff that was offered to me
definitely changed a little bit
um so you know the fancy credits can
definitely help you get to that place
you want to go
what I always tell newer writers is you
know it used to be that you couldn't get
jobs on the fancy shows but now you can
because there's so many shows right and
they sometimes still hire staff writers
but think about your career long term so
it's great that you did a couple of
streaming shows
and you got fancy credits but you
probably didn't go to set you probably
don't barely saw any cuts of the show or
you definitely didn't get to go to post
so your career needs those skills so
that's why I tell them like if you did a
couple of fancy shows go do a season a
broadcast
and first of all you're gonna make
better money because you just make
better money in broadcast and second
you're going to get a chance to do all
that stuff you didn't get to do
and people you know broadcast is its own
animal and it's a different energy and
there's something really pleasing about
breaking a story writing a story going
to see it shot and it making it on the
air in a reasonable amount of time
it's just really joyful for your friends
to not constantly be like when is your
show coming out you're like I don't know
so you know
the fancy credits will help you get some
of the cooler jobs but they will not
necessarily build the skill set that you
need to become a share Runner and run
your own show so I just tell people to
always think about that when they're
looking at the jobs that are getting
offered to them